do some practice examples from our intro
to slope y-intercept exercise what is
the slope of y is equal to negative 4x
minus 3 so you might already recognize
this is in slope-intercept form just as
a reminder slope-intercept form is y is
equal to MX plus b where the coefficient
on this X term right over here that is
our slope and then this constant right
over here that is going to give you your
y-intercept so they're saying what is
the slope here well I just need to
figure out what is the coefficient on
this X term and you can see that the
coefficient here is a negative 4 so that
is going to be our M that is going to be
our slope now just as a reminder you
have to make sure that it's solved in
this way that it is solved for y y is
equal to something times X minus 3 so
that's our slope let's do another one of
these so we're asked what is the
y-intercept of y is equal to negative 3x
minus 2 so once again we already have it
in slope intercept form it's already
been solved for y some of the form y is
equal to MX plus B where m our slope is
given right over here negative 3 but
they're not asking for our slope they're
asking for the y-intercept
well the y-intercept is given by B here
so B is negative to play pay close
attention to the sign here so B is equal
to negative 2 but when I look at these
choices I don't see a B is equal to
negative 2 so what are they talking
about
well the y-intercept is what is the Y
value when X is equal to 0 and you can
see that here X was equal to 0 then that
term goes away and Y is equal to B so if
you want to know the point where the
graph described by this equation
intercepts the y axis well it's going to
be what what is y when x is equal to 0
well when X is equal to 0 Y is equal to
negative 2 and you can see that in our
original
again if X was zero this term would go
away and Y would be equal to negative 2
so 0 comma negative 2 so it would be
that choice right over there on Khan
Academy obviously just have to click on
that you don't have to shade it in let's
do one more complete the equation of the
line whose slope is 5 and y-intercept is
0 comma 4 so once again the general form
is y is equal to our slope times X I
want to put in slope intercept form plus
our y-intercept well they're telling us
our slope is 5 whose slope is 5 so we
know that M is going to be 5 and they
tell us that the y-intercept is 0 4 so
the y-intercept B that is the value of y
when x is equal to 0 so the value of y
when x equals 0 is this 4 right over
here so that is going to be 4 so I could
say Y is equal to 5 times X plus 4 and
when you're actually entering it on Khan
Academy you would just type it in or if
you're using the app you would use it
with your finger and I always make the
mistake of writing y equals and I type
in y equals 5x plus 4 notice she already
gave you the y equals right over there
but that's all you have to do recognize
the slope the y-intercept and then
remember what the slope-intercept form
actually is